why would you want to insult the profit
for billions of people why would you
want to do that very ironically you're
the same woman that said oh if she was
13 or 12 I would have understand on what
basis is 13 and 12 okay to say that a 13
or 12 or 13 year old girl should have
intimacy you can get done for that so
are you a pedophile
do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad arshad Muhammad arshad has
helped develop all of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this course
but also part of me is now saying why
would you want to insult the profit for
billions of people why would you want to
do that I'm not saying you I'm not even
I don't want to make the argument
against free speech I didn't say you
couldn't be allowed to this is a
sensitive subject I'm just saying what
kind of person wakes up and thinks I
want to do that I don't know I just
don't think that's a healthy mindset
like when I see these satanists and
they're especially in America and
they're doing let's keep it on
Christianity these satanists and they're
dressing up Jesus as gay and all this
stuff like that's not done in any kind
of good faith there's no good reason to
do that that's done with genuinely
malicious intentions just perley has
exposed her true phase and her hostility
as we can see at the beginning we
thought maybe it's ignorance benefit or
doubt but as we saw that apparently she
recently joined two Psychopathic
mentally ill individuals who one of them
who claims to be an ex-muslim can't even
recite the shortest verse of the Quran
and is somebody who also claims that
there is nothing wrong with incest and
specifically when I spoke to him asked
him if there is anything wrong with him
having intimacy with his own daughter or
his own son the question the answer was
in the negative meaning there is nothing
wrong morally that's what you get 24
atheism and then you've got the other
crackhead who smashed his father's head
in and you can see these people are out
of their mind and they've desecrated the
Quran many times and they've been
exposed hijab and many others for that
matter and she decides to go and join
them now let's talk to pearly because
she is from America the United States of
America us and a well in usna more than
200 000 children were married in the US
over the last 15 years let's carry on
look what article says three 10 year
olds and an 11 year old boy were amongst
the youngest to it unbeligal loopholes
which allow miners to marry in certain
circumstances the minimum age for
marriage across most of the US is 18 but
but every state has exemptions such as
parental consent or pregnancy which
allow young children to tie the knot so
in 20 states in America
children 200
000 kids have been married underage are
they pedophiles is this a pedophile
country are you from a pit of our
country are you are you I really want to
know does this make what were you going
to say about that not only that if you
look at it for example what the Catholic
church or the church have done and we
know what they are known for the problem
is which is very ironic and funny we
Muslims are not known for this issue you
do not see the Muslim population of
Muslim for that matter getting their
kids married at a certain age when
they're a child they haven't reached the
age of puberty now you're going to be
saying well hold on a second Ali you
know what about the prophet Muhammad
let's go to the prophet peaceful for him
now there are those who should try to
sugar content among the Muslim Community
please shut up and be quiet okay she was
six yes
6 when she did the marriage contract but
she the marriage was consummated when
she became an adult to the standards of
1400 years ago when she was nine years
old which shows us that the prophet
Muhammed peace be upon him made the
marital contract wasn't actual marriage
in the sense where it was you're married
but he waited for her to become an adult
which was three years time if the
prophet Muhammad peace with him had his
inclinations his way his first wife was
Khadijah if you read the Sarah the
sealed nectar the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him his wife was 40 years old
and he was 25 years 25 years old if he
was as you guys make it out to be this
woman just purely talking about a screw
maybe you've been screwed over so many
times maybe it's made you lose a few
screws in your head so maybe you should
be decent enough to ask questions if you
are sincere so that's why I tell Andrew
Tates Nicole and Tristan to not trust
this vile individual woman so the point
is what the prophet peace be opponent
waited three years for her to become an
adult and an adult the definition of
adult is what yeah it is what what is
the definition of a child what is this
new concept of teenager that was made in
the industrial revolution
Etc so these terms and these ages have
been given Left Right Center in Francis
15 in the UK 16 in certain countries 18
who decides which age is right that's
why Islam says it's not one shoe fits oh
that's why I had a discussion with a
lovely gentleman who understood and it
was sincere unlike like this just pearly
girl who was just hostile watch that
video and you can see how if somebody's
genuine and sincere you can see that
they ask questions and when they get to
reply they either accept or reject
respectfully but this man understood
where it was coming from so the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him 1400 years
ago that was the Norms none of his
enemies ever attacked him for this none
of them ever came and said why are you
marrying a six-year-old girl and
consuming the marriage at night because
we say she was an adult in Islam it's
not one shoe fits all Islam says maybe
that girl like for example if we go by
science we can say girls that are
menstruating are ready to conceive their
body biologically saying they are ready
to conceived but Islam says no maybe
she's not ready maybe there's a harm
Factor there is many elements Islam
takes into account rather than just
saying she's 16 now she's gonna have sex
we know the teenage pregnancy problem in
the UK so what we're going to see is
that what if a 16 year old girl is not
ready to have sex but the uklo says
she's legal but what if she is not ready
that's why Islam caters for the
well-being of women by not giving it an
age but saying each individual has to be
assessed and as Muslims we follow this
prophetic tradition and somebody might
ask well then why don't you get married
at or allow your daughters to get
married at night well very simply I'll
give you an example the fact that the
prophet Muhammad waited from six to nine
shows us that we take the prophetic
example for all times if my son wants to
marry a girl and my son is 17 years old
and the girl is 14 we would say we learn
from the prophet Muhammed peace be upon
him that you need to wait for her to
become an adult to the definition of the
UK law no problem that is what we learn
so it is for all times for those who are
saying oh would you allow your daughter
to get married when she's an adult yes
Aisha became an adult at night in
today's time there are many differences
and very ironically you are the same
woman that said oh if she was 13 or 12 I
would have understand is it is that
right on what basis is 13 and 12 okay we
can come and see legally that's illegal
for you to say that to say that a 13 or
12 or 13 year old girl should have
intimacy you can get done for that so
are you a pedophile are you because
you're seeing we're looking at the
prophet Muhammad at that time that was
the norm that was that was the norm at
that time because she became an adult at
night but today we people are given a
legal age of 15 16 but you're saying if
she was 13 or 12 I would have been okay
with it legally you are not allowed to
say that legally you be crossed as a
pedophile but that's besides the point
guys I wanted Tristan Tate say he's not
even a Muslim himself but look at him
being not hostile that's what Allah says
in the Quran the people of the book are
not the same right look what he said
when people complain at it was a
different time they literally focus on
the prophet Muhammad and the Middle East
that was the seventh century you live in
England right Madame yes if you you live
in England right in this country if you
read William blackstone's book on
British common law girls would betrothed
at the age of seven in your country
Google how old princess Isabel was when
she married Richard the Second of
England over 800 years later she was six
years old do you see how as a non-muslim
the respect that he has and he make
sense of it by saying this happened in
history compare that to this hostile
filthy animal pearly I wish I'd come and
confront her I wish I come across her in
public I'll be definitely confronting
her so just barely if you see me be
ready for a civil dialogue with you
inshallah till next time